say to me I'm going to marry you for x
amount of money or present for x amount
of time if you're watching this and
you've done temporary marriages because
of me I am in front of the world I am
saying do you want to speak with
confidence like these amazing
personalities every single one of these
amazing speakers have taken the same
program with brother Muhammad Arad
Muhammad Arad has helped develop allot
of us extremely beneficial to do this
course definitely recommend this
course to access the free life-changing
training
now brothers and sisters and dear
friends somebody sent me this video of
modin now obviously when it comes to
videos I usually try not to watch it
because yes you know people use it as
like he's a comedian Etc just makes
people laugh etc for that matter but
some things are brother and sisters he's
mocking the dean and this can mount to
kufur I'm not saying it's a CF I'm just
saying the action itself can be kufur
you know mockery of praying and and this
that kind of stuff however the video was
actually quite serious and I was quite
shocked to hear moldin dead serious what
was he talking about he was talking
about muta marriage which is temporary
marriage which is which is forbidden in
Islam it was allowed at one moment of
time here is the video of him actually
conducting a muta marriage and then
we're going to see him repenting and we
applaud him for his repentance here's
the video Let's watch the first one of
him conducting the marriage well a uh
invalid marriage and then we'll see his
repentance video wait wait cover this
cover where's the
let put this is my M right it listen all
right say to me in Arabic say to me in
Arabic right now you're going to say to
me I'm going to marry you for x amount
of money or present for x amount of time
I will respond in Arabic saying I accept
one second darling please don't
interrupt the marriage ceremony
sorry we're getting married and you're
talking while we're getting married
please yeah so I'm going to say to you
in Arabic I will marry you for x amount
of time for x amount of dowy dowy means
a present okay you will say that to me
in Arabic I will respond to you in
Arabic saying I have accepted the
marriage okay what is it that you want
as a present for your mut
marriage if you're watching this and
you've done temporary marriages because
of me I am in front of the world I am
saying I Repent to God
I I ask God to forgive me I only promote
permanent marriage if you've ever seen
any videos of me temporary marriage or
promoting or talking about it I take
everything back I'm not involved in any
of that all I know is permanent marriage
all I promote is permanent marriage and
that's the best thing to do in life I'm
not involved all to forgive me on the
day of judgment I ask Allah to forgive
me I hope the world see this I hope
anyone who's doing it because of me or
whatever they see that I've taken back
everything I say I'm not involved on a
day of judgment if you try and say om
told us to do this I'm not I'm saying
right right now I'm clarifying myself
I'm making it clear to the world I only
promote permanent marriage I do not
promote temporary marriage God forgive
me for all my sins and this is I can
only make a video and say I don't know
what else to do if there's anything else
I can do let me know in the comments and
I st for that's all I can say so guys
you heard that for yourself the first
one is obviously again it's it's kind
kind of mockery but again he is
repenting now there's a few things I
want to mention for specifically sisters
who are listening to this um some people
try to equate missar marriage with M
okay m is a temporary marriage and it is
void in Islam and it's very ironic
actually when it comes from from the
Shia again I don't want this to be a
conflict thing I'm not here to cause you
know uh um conflict between the Shia and
sunnis I'm just stating facts this the
irony is that this is narrated by Ali
where he talked about how it was made
forbidden um so it's very very clear
it's in sah Muslim inkari as well that
it was abated it was allowed at one
specific time because Islam is a
pragmatic religion it deals with the
reality of the world and one it was
allowed and like I said before um it was
made forbidden why for many reasons even
when it comes to miss marriage brother
sisters there's a big misconcep
misconception as if it's the same as m m
is something that is done temporarily
okay so you having agreement again this
is Haram in Islam for two people to get
married even it's m marriage to give it
a time a stipulate a time is not
permissible yes if somebody has the
intentions that they are going to
divorce the girl or the woman has
intention that she's going to ask for
divorce whenever this is not necessarily
permissible why because you are in
innately the is valid but you are doing
an action that is Haram so you are you
will be sinful for that and not only
that you are dealing with human beings
these are emotions that people have you
cannot just jump into things missar is
something where again people look at it
very oddly but for some reason a woman a
non-muslim woman a western woman can
choose to consent to have one night
stand with an absolute stranger that
they don't know but a missal marriage
where the woman forgo her rights and it
is at her discretion she can choose and
say I you do not need to provide for me
or you don't need to spend this much
nights with me or you don't have to um
do this AB she can stipulate it as as
long as it's at her discretion she's
happy and then it is go ahead so it's
not the same as a temporary marriage
like a girlfriend boyfriend like a like
like a Zen session or whatever you know
oh I'm just going to be with you for a
couple of weeks Etc and then not per and
then I'm going to leave M marriage is
not the same M marriage is a big big
solution to many many uh problems
however if it's done correctly but again
my dear sisters who I need to speak to
is the following that this is the reason
why I always stipulate and say my dear
sisters ask for a decent amount of of
Mah have your guardian a true Guardian
especially for our re sisters not
somebody who is like yeah I'll be your
guardian you know this is not a true
individual why you want somebody that
genuinely cares about your well-being
like their own sisters their own mother
their own wife their own daughters not
somebody who says I'm just going to be
your guardian there for a little bit and
then I'm going to um do whatever do you
get what I'm trying to say you need
somebody who is genuinely going to care
for you warn you and say look you sure
about this man do you do diligence of
this man and ask for a decent Mah again
look I'm I'm just giving my I'm a nobody
3,000 4,000 why because if a man has ill
intentions and he wants to be with you
for just intimacy or for whatever the
Mah being small is going to be it's not
going to be a deterrent you having a
guardian that is not a true Guardian
it's his friend or is somebody that he
knows ex whatever again it's not going
to I'm being genuinely honest if it was
my own daughter whoever it is sisters
you are putting yourself in this mess if
you go ahead with that now coming toin
again like Allah says in the Quran
in
so for modin or anyone for that matter
Allah says all my servants have TR rest
against himself do not ever despair the
mercy of Allah indeed Allah is the most
forgiving very merciful so again look M
you're a human being whoever is for that
matter we all sin yes that's why it's so
important that we do not to judge people
based on their past Islam is a religion
that says no matter how sinful past you
have you've repented you've acknowledged
it's done and dusted however
mod I'm just being real with you I was
spoking through in the park jokey this
that Etc like you know but put that to a
side I'm having a real discussion with
you okay let's put jokes to us idea is
this bro that you need to understand
there's violations against Allah subh
and there's violations against human
beings that's why the conditions are
free conditions the one who wrongs does
a sin against Allah subhana tala you
hate the sin you stop the sin and you
don't go back to the sin in you try not
to go back to the sin the fourth
condition if you violated somebody's
rights you came out and said something
which is not Allah has not legislated
you may something that is Haram Halal
okay now even to your religion again I'm
not going to say religion what the sect
that you follow still now you can repent
but those people who followed your suit
followed you who I don't know what kind
of they have because you're not a
personal knowledge I mean it's like me
talking I'm not trying to it's like me
saying a or whatever yeah is again they
brought on you might be responsible I'm
not trying to make you feel bad but at
the end of the day you made a statement
and a responsible statement that maybe
you're doing this video because a sister
called you and said her life was
destroyed cuz somebody came and used or
whatever it is for that matter I don't
know what happened because you seem very
serious and you seem very scared so
you're making a disclaimer is there
something about to come out we don't
know so the point is what that's why the
salaf would say we would rather commit
70 sins between us and Allah then one
sin violating the rights of somebody
else and Islam is very very severe when
it comes to this matter so please please
understand that when you're making stuff
and saying stuff it's not a joke yes it
is not a joke it is heavy especially
when it involves the rights of others
how many people how many women how many
females were probably used and abused
because of something that you said yeah
again the people who follow this they
have to blame themselves but the point
is be very very careful guys what you
say because the rights of another person
is severe in Islam very severe so I'm
going to say brother and s in when it
comes to this staff hamdulillah there
are things that are permiss Allah is
allowed and legislated again in Islam we
have a beautiful concept which is M that
is if at a woman's discretion if she is
happy and says I am a doctor full-time
doctor I have one day a week for to
myself I would like a man in my life
I've got kids whatever Islam has a
beautiful solution and if it is done
correctly alhamdulillah it is a solution
where an individual can get married in a
Halal way again Z is something that is
punishable alhamd we have something
permissible and I just want to say in
also be careful especially re sisters
when it comes to the stuff have a
guardian who cares about you please do
not jump to anything number two have a
decent Mah and make sure that he does
things in a decent way you have a
wedding you have a wima whatever it is
for that matter inshah um not saying
it's it's a must but it'll be better and
may Allah subh forget forgive and I will
tell him to look inshah look into Islam
insh and see thatd this is the truth and
the h insh